E aí
[Música]
é
uma pessoal de energia magnífica cara
quando começou agora representar eu
comecei a arrepiar imaginar tudo que a
gente tá indo para construir acho que o
passado nos ensina muitas coisas
lembro quando comecei a empreender em
2009 quantas vezes eu pensei em desistir
eu quero falar um pouquinho para vocês
sobre um assunto que ela é muito
delicado Talvez algumas pessoas no final
do vício vão discordar do que vou falar
principalmente o mexer com a minha
classe os empreendedores só Primeiro
passo é nós acreditarmos e entender o
que é ser empreendedor e é mesmo a
primeira desconstrução eu tenho vários
vários colaboradores se ele tem o cara
que tem carteira de trabalho que hoje eu
considero um mais empreendedor do que
vários várias pessoas que eu conheço
como empresários
a ser empresário não quer dizer que você
é empreendedor nós estamos separar essas
coisas primeira coisa na minha teoria e
empreender é o ato de você fazer algo ou
seja eu posso ser uma pessoa voluntária
e fazer algo do eu posso ter uma
pessoa voluntária não ter um CNPJ e ser
um baita empreendedor E se o primeiro
passo para nós desconstruirmos O que é
empreender só que na nossa vida acontece
algumas coisas são engraçadas quando eu
comecei a empreender em 2009 eu comecei
a primeira como empresário Eu queria
ganhar dinheiro queria ficar milionário
eu achei que ia ter liberdade financeira
recomeçar algumas coisas não dá muito
certo sobre no início tudo é flores eu
tinha saído de uma instituição privada
um banco privado fui começar a
empreender comecei com deu tudo super
certo várias contratos muitas pessoas do
meu lado mas quando as coisas começaram
a dar errado aí papaizinho eu entendi o
que que era ser empresário empreendedor
Na verdade eu a expectativa de ser
empresário de ganhar dinheiro só depois
eu vi que eu precisava ser empreendedor
só para descobrir que empreender é
complexo e difícil primeira coisa é o
que como que tu sai de casa todos os
dias na segunda-feira com vontade de
fazer acontecer mesmo não recebendo lado
em 2009 quando comecei a empreender Tudo
está dando certo em 2011 tudo deu errado
com 59 cheques devolvidos mais de 500
mil reais e dívida e ninguém do meu lado
pouquíssimas pessoas talvez a minha mãe
quero empreendedor mas nunca teve um
CNPJ com terceira série era mais
empreendedor do que muitas pessoas que
naquela época eram meus clientes eram
meus amigos
eu comecei a entender uma coisa cara eu
quero ser um empreendedor eu não quero
mais ser um empresário eu comecei falar
com pessoas que eu acreditava na época
que era um empreendedores eu comecei a
ouvir algumas coisas como assim qual é o
teu propósito Porque que tu acorda todos
os dias você só foca em dinheiro mas
será que dinheiro é tudo e várias
perguntas que foram feitas na época me
fizeram pensar que literalmente eu teria
que desconstruir a minha carreira e como
excluir novamente e uma coisa que eu
prometi para mim mesmo que eu jamais
deixaria as pessoas me levarem para
conformidade por muito tempo na roda de
empresários eu ouvi a coisas como é
difícil de contratar as a série mais
trabalhar balela as pessoas querem só
nós que não estamos incentivando elas a
maneira correta E aí quando eu comecei a
entender que o empresário reclamava eu
comi empreendedor não precisava e não
queria mais reclamar eu me afastei e
comecei a entender uma coisa que eu
precisava estudar mais eu precisava me
aperfeiçoar mais e principalmente estar
na roda de pessoas que quisessem
construir e não destruir naquele mesmo
momento que eu comecei construí minha
carreira como empresa o empreendedor eu
comecei a entender que as pessoas que
estão do meu lado começaram aceitar um
pouco mais o que era o Alexandre sair de
uma dívida de 500 mil reais com muitas
pessoas falando você é fracassado presta
atenção nessa palavra que geralmente o
empreendedor ele é taxado como
fracassado porque tentativa e erro eu
errei muito mais do que a cerveja
Olá meus erros eu tive cheques
devolvidos
pessoas que me falaram que eu não ia
conseguir pessoas que me chamaram para
mesa para falar da minha dívida com eles
e falar assim você é um fracassado
e no final de um grande ciclo de quase
dois anos eu consegui recuperar todos os
meus chefes e todas minhas dívidas
e naquele momento eu comecei a entender
que Aquelas mesmas pessoas que eram os
empresários começaram a se aproximar de
novo e eu falei cara me desculpe mas o
que eu quero para minha vida não é isso
não mente e desde então nós começamos a
mostrar para várias pessoas o que
realmente ao empreendedorismo conheço
hoje pessoas que estão como a gente
chama muitas vezes chão de fábrica não
gosta dessa frase chão de fábrica mas
são mais empreendedor de muitas vezes do
que o senhor diretor lá em cima são
pessoas mais humanas pessoas que
conseguem construir coisas muito maiores
que qualquer empresário EA gente começou
dar atenção diferente para as nossas
empresas hoje
e eu tenho vários sócios que vieram meus
dois funcionários que nós incentivamos
eles a estar conosco mas principalmente
não me conformei teoria da conformidade
ou seja volta para a sociedade chego na
minha casa e as pessoas falam você não
consegue volto para minha comunidade as
pessoas fala você não consegue de uma
coisa para você nunca desista dos seus
sonhos não desista dos sonhos porque se
você não tem o CNPJ não tem problema
você pode empreender na sua vida
primeira coisa você acreditar que
realmente aquilo que você faça vale a
pena ser feito segundo você acreditar
que aquilo que você faz existe amor
envolvido vão estar aqui hoje eu vi um
grande desafio para o Alexandre
e ela realmente vir aqui de corpo e alma
me entregar o máximo possível para esse
momento assim como eu faço sempre decidi
fazer a minha apresentação sem slides
para tentar trazer para você na minha
Moção de agora
é porque essa construção do agora é
muito importante na vida de um
empreendedor
porque muitas vezes em sai de casa como
empresário e a gente não viveu agora a
gente vive no final do mesmo a d r r no
final de um ciclo um lucro Não tô
dizendo que isso não é importante óbvio
que é eu também olho para indicadores
Mas isso não pode ser o fim não pode seu
fim se nós vivemos digamos 100 anos o
que que a gente vai fazer vivendo 100
anos qual história que eu vou contar lá
no final da minha vida será que vai ser
o saldo da minha conta bancária como
empresário ou as histórias como
empreendedor Eu convido todos vocês
acreditar que o empreendedorismo é única
forma de a gente mudar a vida das
pessoas por isso que eu defendo que o
empreendedorismo e a chave da vida é a
única forma que a gente consegue
realmente mudarão o mundo que todos nós
aqui estamos buscar buscando mudar nós
queremos segundo mundo só o que que a
gente tá fazendo
e quais são as ações que nós estamos
fazendo para mudar esse mundo
e quando eu chego e converso com o
empresário peço para ele velho se você
reclama tanto que não tem jovens
qualificados ou com vontade de trabalhar
o que que você está fazendo qual o tipo
de qualificação que você está
proporcionando para essas pessoas Ah mas
eu não vou ganhar nada com isso cara
Dani se você não vai ganhar lá no futuro
se você investir hoje no futuro pessoas
os seus concorrentes vão pegar todos
esses essa energia e vamos colocar na
empresa deles não tem problema só Deus
não podemos acreditar que a nossa vida
simplesmente é olhar para a última linha
não pode ser
e lembre-se dos fracassados
muitas pessoas
e hoje estou em casa estou aqui
imaginando que não tem opção que são
fracassados porque alguém disse porque
alguém falou que você não consegue
é mentira
todos nós podemos
e eu faço você pode fazer
é só que muitas vezes acreditamos que o
impossível é verdade só que será que não
é uma opinião
eu não consigo uma pessoa pode ser que
não seja impossível para mim porque se
eu acredito fielmente naquilo Talvez o
impossível seja uma questão de tempo
para você provar que você pode ser a
pessoa que você quer ser não deixe
ninguém ceifar seus sonhos ninguém pode
ser Faro os seus sonhos nenhum
empresário nenhuma pessoa
e lembre-se que para gente construir um
mundo melhor a gente precisa aprender
mais eu tenho certeza absoluta que se
nós levarmos essa causa para frente
mostrar que realmente o empreendedorismo
ele pode salvar vidas ele salvou a minha
Ele salvou minha vida quando eu
acreditei que eu poderia fazer ele
comecei a construir ele salvou minha
vida
ah e hoje é minha obrigação
mostrar para outras pessoas têm
empreendedorismo também pode salvar a
vida delas
Oi Para o Futuro as pessoas ainda podem
me chamar de fracassado porque eu não
sei disso eu vou dar certo para sempre
pode ser que tudo que eu construir eu
perca tá tudo bem porque alguma coisa
não vou perder as histórias
e eu não vou perder as histórias que eu
comprei
uma vez eu falar para fracassado
já ouvi várias pessoas
e hoje
o bolso
é porque incomoda
e geralmente o empreendedor incomoda ele
tira outras pessoas vão de conforto ele
mostra o impossível
e quando ele mostra impossível as
pessoas tem que correr atrás
bom então lembre-se sempre que você for
fazer algo diferente as pessoas podem
ser categorizado como um fracassado para
tentar tirar o teu sonho para te colocar
de volta para dentro da caverna porque a
lá que elas querem que você fique
e lembre-se uma coisa e fracassados eles
também sofrem
e eu sonhei por muito tempo
Ah e ainda continuo sonhando Espero que
essas mesmas pessoas para sempre me
considera um fracassado
porque eu sou um fracassado muito feliz
sempre graça
[Música]
E aí